scp-343 vs scp-076  the anomaly that claims to be god versus  god's favorite grandson abel what would  happen if the two ever went toe-to-toe  in terms of raw combat prowess  scp-076 would undeniably be the stronger  option he's one of the deadliest  humanoid combatants ever known and his  ability to produce deadly blades from  thin air makes him equally resourceful  scp-343 while not a standard combatant  does have immensely powerful reality  warping abilities it's possible that his  non-standard fighting methods would  allow him to get the jump on able whose  skill is also rather conventional  clinching him the last minute win after  all in a fight against god god often  wins